hello I'm Tom Ellis from Lucifer on
Netflix and today I shall be reading
your first tweets first things first
or first things first someone make Tom
Ellis read first tweets please well
they're doing that right now cuz that's
that's exactly what I'm doing
Tom Ellis got some sweet bejesus carved
abs sweet lord of the dark
hashtag Lucifer on Netflix some sweets
but Jesus carved ABS they're not quite
as carb as they were when I shot that
video but I've had a couple of beers
sweet bejesus me I'm thirsty
mum you've just had a drink me the first
for Tom Ellis never stops I can't read I
can't read something that says mum on it
without thinking about Tricia Helfer
miss Charlotte Richards so I'm imagining
that Suze who's this this is prom next
gosh I'm thirsty I want the government
to create a law where Tom Ellis can't
wear a shirt he has to be shirtless 24/7
I'm not sure everyone would agree with
that and I don't want to you know be
responsible for some cardiac arrests
across the country so maybe we should
leave that rule for now there's more
important pressing government issues I
think at the moment this one simply
reads I think it's a poem Tom Ellis is
daddy
I repeat Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy Tom Ellis is
daddy Tom Ellis is daddy I didn't
realize I had quite so many kids I'm
only living to see Tom Ellis is but Tom
Ellis is but what would be my response
to that this video watch season forward
you won't have to wait long to see that
freshly cleaned and shaved Tom Ellis
makes me so wet
that for tweets oh it's from a lifeguard
there we go that's good
oh here oh this one starts yeah hi we
need to talk about what a damn snack Tom
Ellis is in Lucifer ripped me in half
and send me to hell well it's always
nice to be part of someone's five a day
you know I'm happy that I'm one of your
damned snacks that's lovely
rip me in half and send me to hell
that's quite violent don't you think an
alginate underhill oh I would let Tommy
let's get alfresco on me if you catch my
drift which means the outside which is
also a little bit rude it does remind me
of an episode of Miranda where we talk
about doing I shall eat old my mum today
that I want Tom Ellis to dick me she
respectfully agreed I hope that's a typo
and I didn't realize dick was a was a
verb just uh yeah I'm gonna move on from
that one I think I think I've dict
anyone for a while Tom this is all caps
as well Tom Ellis in glasses owns my ass
so there you go on now the proud owner
of your backside there we go then thanks
for the for the glasses big up like that
one oh goodness means he's got lots of
stars in it so I think they could be
sort of swearing real talk at Tom Ellis
17 could seriously star star star might
star star star he can shove his star
star star star in my star star star star
star star star star star please sir I am
a star star star star star star star
fill in the blanks I'd rather not - but
what I do like about this one is that it
goes slightly Shakespearean after the
cursing to say please sir please sir
will you star star star me up the star
star star please this might be something
to do with the tight jeans but this just
says Tom Ellis just looks like he has a
really long dick answers on the
postcards - does Tom Ellis have a really
long dick at dick Shire Nick and
goodness me these are quite racy aren't
they I just want to say Tom Ellis is the
biggest DILF on this planet and I want
him to wait for a wall thank you for
listening to my TED talk quite a violent
thrust to get you through a wall
especially if it's like a brick wall
goodness me can we start with like a
plaster board wall and and move on from
there and I'll have to do some
kettlebell training to get my thrust
going to keep properly through that wall
at Tom Ellis I need to stop watching
Lucifer before bed really freaks my
boyfriend out when he wakes up to me
moaning Lucifer mint
me too me moaning okay I thought your
boyfriend was moaning Lucifer Quinn
which I wouldn't be complaining about as
we are representative on the show of all
sexuality but yeah just don't watch it
before bed obviously because that would
that would really help you and your
relationship with your boyfriend Tom
Ellis commit in the ass with that
English accent if that were possible I
would and if you do want to be attending
ours with English accent there's
certainly some more English people than
me anybody can get Benedict Cumberbatch
in here he's a rather marvelous as well
with his the old accent he's got a
ten-inch accent did you know that Tom
Ellis can shuff okay breathe Tom Ellis
can shove jelly beans up my ass any
goddamn day he wants and can punch me in
the face
thank you so is the idea that I put the
jelly beans up inside you and I punish
them in your face to get them out again
sort of like a sort of primal vending
machine I like it
well this is the last one please don't
get any dirty are you dirty punch this
is obviously from someone with a sore
throat
why is Tom Ellis so hot lemmie gurgle
that which um you know if you do have a
sore throat that's quite a good idea
actually you know not that I'm I'm
offering to do it to you but if there is
some on hand and I don't mean on your
hand I mean like to like it this and
come around and you got a sore throat
then gurgle neck because it really will
help the old done vocal cords out anyway
those have been you're thirsty tweets
and you really are a filthy Bunch